a new season has come to destiny too and
with it comes a new activity and new
ways to earn gear for your character in
the season of arrivals that new activity
is called contact a public event that
helps you power up a machine called the
prismatic recast er to get cool new
rewards here's a rundown of how contact
works how to activate the heroic version
of the event and how to use the
prismatic recast ER to get all the gear
you want much like the Seraph towers
from last season you'll find contact
rotating between locations each week
either on aisle or untighten the
activity is a lot like gambit you'll
kill waves of enemies who drop items
called motes of darkness and it's your
job to pick up those motes and deposit
them into a bank in the centre of the
area where the event takes place you can
carry up to 10 motes at a time and your
goal is to completely fill the bank to
100% every time you fill the bank you
trigger another order wave of enemies
until you fill it four times completing
all four waves summons a boss enemy
similar to what you see in other public
events contact is pretty straightforward
for anyone who's played gambit in
between each wave you'll face taken
enemies who are much like the blockers
in gambit matches you'll want to kill
these guys as fast as you can they lock
the bank preventing you from depositing
more motes in contact you're racing a
timer that slowly ticks down so the
longer your bank stays locked the closer
you are to failure every so often during
contact you'll see the message
concentrated darkness coalesce is nearby
on screen this is the key to activating
the heroic version of the event when you
see that message look for an orange beam
shooting into the air near a pool of
orange energy on the ground a champion
enemy will spawn nearby kill it and
you'll be able to take an orange orb
called a bloom from the pool of energy
the champion was guarding deposited into
the bank for a big boost in your moat
percentage if you can Bank all the
blooms that spawn during the event
you'll trigger the heroic version you'll
then face a tougher taken boss who has
extra mechanics for you to deal with
contact is tied to the season of
arrivals new reward mechanic called
umbral engrams these random drops are
similar to the other engrams in destiny
- except they can be focused to give you
specific rewards instead of random ones
to focus the engrams you'll need to
power up the new machine in the tower
called the prismatic recast er
completing bounties from the recast er
and playing contact urns
two new kinds of currencies twisted
energy and altered elements you can use
twisted energy to upgrade the prismatic
recast er unlocking new perks to let you
focus on grams into specific kinds of
weapons or armor once you've upgraded it
some you can use the prismatic recast
her to focus any engrams you find even
if you don't focus them you can still
redeem the engrams near The Drifter for
random loot the recast sir will focus
your first three engrams each week for
free but after that you'll need to pay
altered elements so make sure to keep a
healthy stock to help you get the
rewards you're looking for you'll want
to complete contact activities each week
to keep powering up the rear caster and
unlocking new messages from the darkness
from Eris more like the menagerie
activity and the chalice of opulence the
more you improve the racast er the
better your end grim focusing becomes
that allows you to pick what gear you
receive and even the perks and stats
it'll have there is a lot more going on
with destiny too these days we are
expecting to find more secrets in the
season of arrivals so stay tuned for
more coverage and check out GameSpot's
other videos for more coverage on
destiny choose future the newly
announced beyond light expansion and how
the game will appear on next-gen
consoles
[Music]
you